en ce début de semaine focus dans ce
journal sur les missions de nos députés
la première laquelle on pense forcément
c'est celle de voter les lois mais ce
n'est pas la seule mission de nos
députés justement alors quelle est
l'activité nos parlementaires on en
parle avec un invité philippe benassaya
bonsoir bonsoir députés à l'est
républicain de la 11e circonscription
des yvelines on parle avec vous
notamment dans un instant de votre
travail au sein de la commission
spéciale qui porte sur le projet de loi
séparatisme vous avez d'ailleurs posé
une question au gouvernement sur ce
sujet c'était la semaine dernière
également célia de son vol la rédaction
de tv soit 118 avec nos grands plateaux
bonsoir ça avec vous on va voir les
chiffres justes en la participation de
nos députés yvelinois au voc
oui alors la participation au vote des
députés mesure à la présence en
hémicycle
alors comme vous pouvez voir sur cette
infographie michel de vaucouleurs député
modem de la 7e circonscription arrive en
tête de taux de participation au vote
avec 35% et en fin de liste c'est michel
vialay députés à l'ère de la 8e
circonscription avec 7% pourriels brawn
pie v ces chiffres s'expliquent par
l'activité du député qui est varié la
présence dans l'hémicycle et le vote
dans l'hémicycle est vraiment qu'un une
faible 1 qu'un faible indice de notre
activité est beaucoup plus large que
cela et je crois que c'est ça qu'il faut
vraiment que les citoyens comprennent
alors philippe benassaya vous vous avez
un taux de 13 % de participation au fait
pourquoi alors d'abord je vais employer
un mot que vous connaissez très bien ce
genre de classement ce sont des
marronniers chaque année on fait un
classement des magots antiparlementaire
qui consiste à dire les députés ne sont
pas présents dans l'hémicycle et il ne
vote pas les loin ça se passe pas du
tout comme ça pendant 15 jours quelqu'un
leur explique
parce que comme ça on en sort et puis on
n'est pas obligé de se justifier que ce
soit les députés droite d'ailleurs ou de
gauche c'est la même chose
un député un travail en hémicycle dans
lequel il vote soit de manière
électronique avec un bouton pour contrer
abstention soit à main levée la majorité
des projets de loi c'est à dire les
projets du gouvernement
c'est à main levée donc ce n'est pas
comptabilisable
deuxième point on ne peut pas être en
hémicycle toute la journée sur tous les
projets de lois qui sont votées en
hémicycle sinon on passerait du lundi au
dimanche toute la journée et la soirée
et la nuit en hémicycle donc moins de
temps sur le terrain mais ne manquent
pas sauter - temps en commission
spéciale - le temps en commission tout
court - temps au groupe d'études - temps
rendez-vous montant en commission des
finances comme je le suis mais en ce
moment c'est impossible
notre bureau n'est pas dans l'hémicycle
et puis par exemple il va y avoir un
projet de loi sur la maltraitance des
animaux probablement je ne serai pas en
hémicycle parce que ce n'est pas ma
commission ça ne dépend pas de la
commission des finances veut dire on ne
peut pas être tout le temps à 577 dans
l'hémicycle c'est impossible
est ce que quelqu'un peut m'aider à cela
on voudrait qu'elle vise le plaisir
c'est qu'on peut pas avoir un taux de 91
ans et attend si vous avez vu vos
chiffres on est tous entre 30 10 15 20
parce que chacun vote
moi j'ai voté le projet de loi de
finances puisque chez aux commissions la
commission des finances
mais on était une cinquantaine une
centaine dans l'hémicycle sur le
séparatisme on va peut-être en parler on
est on est une certaine aussi le travail
du député se fait sur le terrain lors du
salon célia est ce qu'il ya un moment
plus important qu'un autre pour aller
voter dans l'hémicycle et bien justement
à vous enlève les avait un peu répondu à
la question est bien aussi qu'ils
justifient la présence d'un député dans
l'hémicycle s'est notamment lorsqu'il
s'agit d'un texte qui relève de la
compétence de la commission à laquelle
vous appartenez un indicateur de
présence dans l'hémicycle
c'est le sujet du texte vous ne pouvez
pas être partout nous nous spécialisons
chaud des thématiques et donc en
fonction des sujets vous serez présent
ou pas dans l'hémicycle une session
aussi qui revient ces liasses et skull
députés votent en fonction de son
appartenance politique ou en fonction de
sa conviction personnelle et bien
souvent c'est un mélange des deux mais
pourriels brune qui y est il y a une
liberté de vote pour les députés devant
avoir un groupe et une majorité solide
au service des français
ces facteurs de stabilité stabilité de
nos
titution mais cela n'empêche nullement
de porter sa voix de porter ses
convictions que ce soit envers
l'exécutif envers le gros et dans
l'hémicycle quand cela est nécessaire
rappelons qu'un député a trois missions
principales voter la loi contrôler
l'action du gouvernement et évaluer les
politiques publiques
merci sega pour toutes ces précisions